we had shots and we pushed the ball in
the field and didn't connect sometimes
and obviously you know turn the ball
over four times does not help and that's
that's on me we had guys in the right
spots I just gotta you know put the ball
there
that's mason rudolph after last night's
21 7 lost to the cleveland browns yes
there was a football game played last
night and the Browns win for the second
time in just five days they beat the
bills at home then the turnaround to
beat the Steelers and I'll tell you what
Mason Rudolph did not look good last
night Randy Fichtner the offensive
coordinator was praising him earlier in
the week about how he's improving he's
improving I mean they've been winning
despite him big cat and I know that
you're a big duck Hodges guy and he
crossed my mind more than a few times
last night that maybe Hodges gives them
a better chance to win at this point
maybe Colin Kaepernick gives him a
better chance to win at this point yeah
and if you watch the game that Steelers
defense is fantastic and they played
really really hard last night
they obviously gave up a couple quick
first touchdowns in the first quarter
but they played really really hard and
it was in a you know time and time again
Mason Rudolph put him in bad situations
he turned the ball over and gave the
Browns plus-plus situations where they
could score and that happened so I just
I'm watching this game last night and
I'm saying to myself this Steelers
defense is good enough to get them to
the playoffs if Mason Rudolph can be
just average maybe even a little less
than average for interceptions is
ridiculous and yes juju Smith Schuster
went out and yes James Connor went out
and the offensive line didn't really
block anyone but Mason Rudolph if
anything you can say the spin zone for
the Steelers fans is you found out what
Mason Rudolph is this season and he's
probably not the guy because that's kind
of the question you've seen the Steelers
draft I think for quarterbacks in the
time that Ben Roethlisberger has been in
Pittsburgh you know always having that
guy who's waiting off in the wings
Johnny o Josh Dobbs Dennis Dixon there's
a bunch of guys they've brought in who
said maybe at some point he can be the
guy I think the Steelers are kind of
figuring out that Mason Rudolph might
not be the guy because he was really
really bad last night yeah and you're
right they went through Josh Dobbs and
then they drafted Mason Rudolph remember
Ben Roethlisberger went public and said
what did they screw up the Josh
jobs pick why do they keep drafting
these quarterbacks and here's the
reality
the Steelers had a long 20 years between
Terry Bradshaw and Ben Roethlisberger
where it was a revolving door of
marginal quarterbacks and they would win
with defense despite these flaws on
quarterback and and that's what they're
heading toward they're just gonna have
to wait for Ben Roethlisberger to retire
find their way into the top ten
get another franchise quarterback and
build around that guy and hope that they
pick right and hope that they get a guy
who can come play because the second
third fourth round guys they're drafting
simply don't have it yeah and and again
their defense was fantastic and credit
to the Browns last night because they
seemingly have figured out their goal
line situation they scored twice from
the goal line early on in the game they
finally used a QB sneak a novel concept
in Freddie kitchens offense to maybe
have a play that works like 70% of the
time as your play from the one-yard line
when Baker Mayfield snuck in for the
first touchdown but this story is let
you know of course it's going to be the
fight but the underlying story is the
Browns have kind of fixed their
offensive wolves in the red zone
and Mason Rudolph is most likely not the
guy in Pittsburgh yeah you're absolutely
right now part of the other problem last
night you had juju Smith Schuster who
exited with a concussion James Conner
the top tailback on the Steelers
re-injured the shoulder that knocked him
out of a couple of games and that's the
the problem that the students have had
all year injuries they've overcome
injuries more often than not but too
many guys get injured you get to a point
where you just don't have the bodies you
don't have the skill you don't have the
talent to match what the Browns have I
so last week when we did the show I gave
you Dark Horse Jon Gruden for coach of
the year now obviously the Steelers lost
last night it's gonna be very hard for
them to maybe get that six seed the
wild-card spot although their schedule
is pretty soft down the stretch I think
Mike Tomlin should be a Dark Horse Coach
of the Year candidate because what he
has done to keep this team together you
mentioned the injuries that's September
that was just absolutely abysmal they
get pasted by the Patriots on opening
Sunday Night Football
then Ben gets hurt they deal with all
these injuries they somehow put it back
together and get to five and four
five they last night they had a chance
to go you know six and four I think Mike
Tomlin what he's done not even
mentioning the Antonio Brown the labia
on bail everything that happened the
offseason I think him keeping this
locker room together him keeping the
Steelers competitive week in and week
out
he should get some mentions for coach of
the year even though they won't be good
enough for him to win the award thank
you for reading pro Football Talk calm
and otherwise listening to this program
when you're not on it because we've been
all over the Mike Tomlin for coach of
the year angle and yesterday one of the
points we made they lost to the Patriots
who are eight and one they lost to the
Ravens who are seven and two they lost
to the Seahawks who are eight and two
and they lost to the 49ers who are eight
and one so before last night they had
dealt with a murderer's row of teams who
are among the elite in the NFL and they
lost to each of them they only got blown
out in one of them last night's game was
I think the first wall-to-wall ugly
performance from the Steelers where
other than week one when Ben
Roethlisberger was quarterback but last
night it just felt sluggish
it felt often it was amazing that it was
14 to 7 I know and I kept saying these
guys are gonna find another way to win
and minka Fitzpatrick's gonna end up
with a ball in his hands he's gonna run
it in for a touchdown and it's gonna be
1714 the Steelers win it's a credit to
the Steelers defense the fact that that
game when you watched it and you saw how
bad their offense looked and how bad
they looked on third down and how bad
Mason Rudolph was all night the fact
that he had the ball with what eight
minutes left in a one score game and you
felt like the Steelers could maybe you
know drive and get back into it they
were forget that with 12 minutes left
they were on the 35 or 40 with with a
fourth in one situation where they had a
chance to possibly go in and score a
touchdown so that's just how good the
Steelers defense has been performing
it's been keeping them in games in spite
of their quarterback play now Mike I'll
throw this out there because Mason
Rudolph I have I've been saying is not
really the guy in my eyes and this all
happens last night he has a very poor
performance where the story obviously
this morning is Miles Garrett but will
Mason Rudolph maybe face a one game
suspension will it not even be a
question of should we bench masonry off
for duck Hodges will
shouldn't be taken out of my Tomlin's
hands and he will then have duck Hodges
to go out there and prove himself yet
again and not have to worry about maybe
benching a guy that they've invested in
with the second round draft pick yeah
although I don't buy the idea that what
miles Garrett did was justified because
he was provoked by Mason Rudolph Rudolph
definitely was on the ground trying to
rip the helmet off of Miles Garrett late
in the game he did I don't want to say
he started it because the reaction
grossly exceeded what the provocation
was but Rudolph wasn't blameless in all
of this and that would be something if a
court when do you ever see a quarterback
get suspended for conduct on the
football field of quarterbacks never get
suspended for anything but that's again
and I've been taking the air out of
footballs alive back to the beginning of
the show when we said that Mason Rudolph
is not other quarterbacks because I I
think if this was again Tom Brady Aaron
Rodgers Patrick mahomes deshaun Watson
you can list all the guys this is a
no-doubter he's not gonna get his
pension but because it's Mason Rudolph
and because he hasn't proved himself in
the league
I just wouldn't be shocked if he gets
maybe a game and I I agree with you
wholeheartedly that there's no like well
he started it it guess what how the
world works how the real world works it
doesn't matter who starts it it's who
takes it to that next level that level
that goes beyond like smashing him in
the face with a helmet so start doing
the whole oh well he started it that's
not how the real world ever works but I
wouldn't be shocked if the NFL said hey
we need to at least send a message that
you know getting the ball rolling in
these situations can't be had so we need
to suspend Mason Rudolph for maybe one
game I mean maybe I'm way off maybe I'm
completely off but I wouldn't be shocked
here's an interesting philosophical
question from the NFL's perspective
because if you start handing out
suspensions to others who were involved
in the broader incident you take some of
the focus off of Miles Garrett and I
think that it's more important for the
league to send a clear message to anyone
out there who was horrified by that
visual that we're gonna see over and
over again my guess is that some of the
morning shows the news shows will be
showing it right because they're worried
about
mom and dad saying to their kids
you're never playing football and this
is the kind of thing that will horrify
parents and this is the kind of image
that the NFL is on out there so then
yeah they almost need to make it all
about Miles Garrett and they need to
throw the book at Miles Garrett so the
message to mom and dad is yeah this
horrible thing happened but we are
absolutely not standing for it and this
guy is gonna be suspended for X number
of games I do love that this is you know
this horrifying thing that we don't want
you know how do you say to the children
I love that I love that line you know
whenever you see a million replays Mike
we show right but but it's it's
newsworthy okay it's not inherent I mean
it's not like showing a shooting right
oh but these are the kinds of images the
NFL doesn't want mom and dad to see
because something is causing them to get
their kids to to not play football Jay
Glazer told me story one time you know
he's involved in MMA and he's got that
gym out in California there was a mom
that brought her kid in one day and
wanted to get the kid signed up for MMA
cuz she's looking for something safer
than football and he started laughing
he's like this isn't safer than football
but the perception is out there that
football is this inherently dangerous
sport and when you see well it's
horrible when you see that right there
and you don't know if you just see that
instant you don't know that Mason
Rudolph was fine when it hits him in the
head it looks like he's about to go down
for the count
Mike there was a guy bleeding out of his
ear earlier in the game footballs
football I love it I love football but
come on this I'm telling you I'm telling
you the NFL is concerned about people
seeing these things and saying to the
kids you're not playing football that's
where that's why vantes Burfict ended up
being suspended for 12 games for you
know a within the confines of the game
use of his helmet that the NFL now
frowned upon
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports